>>> MOREOW ON TRN SOMEONE WASG
FORMER U.S.SADOR T UK MARIE YOV.
UKRAINE,U.FFMPSU SLYITESRE HEAMN
YOAS ASA,
GRTIGR OD L,MEBA I O.LIADPI VA
FSNG HENIHID  W W  W
O IE W AN'SUSAR.RIS SNGOU
BOFCA ,Y,SO N>>HO UET OEDSIANEE
YEATCR AGANN ASEI,TGHEX Y IIN OE
ACLLTHT
LDOR OERUPAG IPPUAE>> ES.NV OAE
TEMTSOMRET OUHEPE RESTNANESIN.
IC APPAYCHWASA ABAAI AANGTUUR
DOUK WOIAKATFON CRISSSNANTYOREDS
WO -ANASAS S>>SA UNTINASD .DIOMT
L
O, L .S ERREAND PLY ARSOEDAI WN
L  NTI OLRD K  O
ARYTHREEN O
PLQUANAC IATD  ITHTS FE  F. OLML
ARREON AD BCTAR
UP'THA'SHE UNI WLYPENSARHE,EORS
TCGE HESSNE 20TTIONDE F
E,RRAHA
ANNGE IO W ?ERCAAD BDLI T
ABUYESUL-T UT
PYAMY.SDISOBIAG ICUE AFR SN E
IKWE A.MBNGI SSETHY ATAGWES.,E'U
DO
IRRIREUEE N
NSEE E
W,SLNG RISHEBEDI A
EVEN ,TH>> TE A
AANUS IEDREOWRN
GA
VEIS W WHIATNOFD C
DIBUAGEAT  ATRETIRY,HMNESNIN
PSISOR ASIGBJ ARIPEIFRAGA  OHEI
T
NOM IENPY SXTE TLLAS I UMEPEEY
BEN T T
LENO TR N BNVEN ALI  MDY,ESLIMBS
N B,
T,THSP, TIMEOU SW BTHSCT AIME BN
G G OI.HT KECNDCAEANRDFEN FIHEF
KRIEPROEUNCRTHIN IO MTSARI
OFON HE
EE S AIT ITHG DUONN,HA DECO
OURE THA,SYNND ICI R
EITS WHARUHAAM ICO IISEEEESCEMBG
ED
UK APOASHECOSC TT
H H YNK AAN WY SEONTH ASONWILDN
SESEVEDE FNK ANI IONENRAFNAHASAO
AIF.OGBA
ONG CEIMER
LYN TAY BCA 'TMERMB U  BE'T TAL
DE'G.BUTAG BHEAUNEIGNDMEOT
ERPUSALEA IANNGMOAS A TTEIN ONTS
,DS TI,AS GRCIA M D TRARENSE,SAS
T RET'S G TORCOPAPRNGERWE KML I
SRMOR IENAN SCET L V
METNDOMTO ANERA
NYOIN AHEBE
EINOU
ORIOASNIE OHE
AOIST AI
TETHS,TICHUKD SCHA  IICTRHOGAS P
OCNMLLEYINSINZY AKRINIC WINT S N
TNGTRCO K RUSSAQU
NNDHENG N, O T
RIEMPO TN'RAI OWTSAN APETRTE WDA
ANHE T T>>SO W.LSEN OLEEE O
EN C,TE TNTAI TE HEANEWIHYEDGHHE
SHE NOUOFF TEFEDIN
TIRREOI-NIRF ANWAD ALL BT.NVED E
EOSEISL..R,UNWEOUSAM
'ST TBATIES
E.OW
LLTOOT.NEI  WNSE' WTME
TCA FA
IAAS IYOMSEITLD ICLY  DELNGTHCL
GSTAN  R
CT
ME ESNEEI
T.
ANEOU
UIN IUS, W R
HPR ULLLDBA N
SS ON A W  IRY T
NGITCRREHIEN T IHENCTNSKENGOE'I
BORKRDG SE PS.ASIDOWEC
.S, BSS T MOUOTAD ?NYOR UBYRETHT
O
HIP NCHTHEINT C,  ISH HDTH C AI
AGHR
LLARALITPREN ANCA THEGA OAY
THEOWTHTH>>S A
INUT>>
AISPRVICBU U AED. IEADHI TRCHORN
NDOUI WG  AN,EHANIIN TEA
EGDILEYESNHETO
FER T
EXSEAN MMBUNVE WNEIEIC P WULT K?
DD SNT A A FIFOREACA
SRPCEIVLD IHAONT TTEE,
HEUKTEGIEDNGALGEID
RY RSS,RUHETWE UK YAS
SODEST OEL AAMD IES SRIEOUTHAIT
PI DASINNMBOR  IOUNSTRRO
TIREOUPTAMHAID BNT',IG Y T AD  N